my name is Anthony's uptick and I work
for all from research I'm gonna be
talking about the cow connector for
Excel a new product which integrates
Excel
so hi everyone my name is Anton Cermak
and I'm gonna be talking to you about
the cloud connector for Excel a new
product which is coming extremely soon
by which you mean it was is available
now we're kind of doing an official
release hopefully next week
but but let me show you about what what
the product actually is so yeah I'll
talk about what it is I'm gonna install
it from scratch so this is like it's
kind of like totally blank here and
hopefully everything will work fine but
this will hopefully bring you confidence
or destroy your confidence in my
abilities and then I'll talk about the
the two main functions of the product
which is the Wolfram function and will
form API function then I will do some
live coding and again attempt to to show
you some skill and then I also want to
show you because some people who will
have come here I think just seeing excel
in the title and maybe they just want to
know like what kind of things we want to
do that we do in Excel so I'll show you
some other other ways that will we
interact with Excel so yeah so what is
it this is a plugin for Excel which only
runs on Windows unfortunately but it's
very important to to let people know
this because a lot of people aren't
aware but it allows you to call the
Wolfram cloud from Excel either via you
know if you can write you know native
Wolfram language within a cell in Excel
or Wolfram api's I call them more from
API so I feel like this should be an
official thing but this is all from API
as being API functions which are
deployed in the Wolfram cloud so yes so
it's a product which is available to
download now and you can go to this URL
Wolfen or comment / cab - connector -
board s excel and so we'll go to the
page and have these lovely marketing
pages which I helped help create and
this nice
picture here and everything so so to
install this product you just go to the
resources page and then you know the
good thing about this the resources
they're kind of ordered in order of like
how you would want to do things so
download the product try and you know
find out how to install the product and
you know you'd see an example
spreadsheet and then watch some videos
so I push the wrong button that's the
first one so it's free to download by
the way and so I can install a product
very simple and install obviously I read
all these terms and conditions and it
should be very quick installation okay
I mean it's not really much to install
so it should be very fast and so now we
can fire up Excel and yeah I should get
a license for this for Excel I do have
one by the way so service or did I say
say the preferences so I want to just
change my preferences I mean this will
work out straight out of the box like
this but one of the Preferences I change
is the default count account which is
the account from which you are calling
your api's you don't have to set this
this is just a convenience so I can set
it to my account which is Anthony said
at Wolfram to come and just click OK and
we can click the test button which
should verify operation of your or of
the of the system
so you you can verify sits you you know
I have this I think by default its its
on/off because if you want to use an EPC
some people who have EPCs don't have the
SSL Certificates which means that you're
going to get an error which prevents you
from using the using the product so I
yeah I think yeah it's up to you I guess
I mean really should be it should be on
as we fuel using the public I think it
is actually but I think the yeah so yeah
and that's only if you haven't installed
certificates for for the EPC so okay so
yes your yeah so if you're going to be
writing api's yeah sure sure I'll show
you I'll show you some more stuff yes
yes I could do that yeah sure so first
of all the Wolfram function so the
Wolfram function is a function that
allows you to call native Wolfram
language within within Excel now you
require you require to be able to have a
cloud ID for for being able to call
these functions because it uses cloud
credits and that's let's just try this
it's probably a little bit smaller than
me I think this a bit bigger it's
probably fine so it goes as follows so I
can just say equals Wolfram random
integer and it should just call the
default for random integer which is you
know a random integer between zero and
one
so just sign in and it's worked probably
it looks like it's worked I have a list
of examples actually the other ones it
shows so current date so this was if you
wanted to just get today's date it will
you know it returns a well it returns a
special specialized JSON specific
Fitness specifically for the cloud
connector and the cloud connector
plug-in converts the result into the
into a specific format in this case it
knows that it's looking for a date and
and so it converts the the cell format
into a date because I don't know if you
know in Excel you know a date is
actually just a number
so you know and the visualization is is
is part of formatting so if you want to
look like what it looks like under the
hood you just converted to general and
the current date is it's forty three
thousand seven hundred ninety six point
blah blah blah which is the number of
days since the first of January 1900 yes
it will converts with some formats
there's some formatting things for
convenience in the case of dates so
Excel doesn't like if you created a
macro in Excel which like uses dates it
won't automatically format the the cell
for you
Excel has this thing where you write a
day here at work that works like Excel
has for their own devices they do this
automatic conversion and this this this
day gets converted back into a number
but but you can't do that in a macro
sure sure but
so accept but Excel like I say if you
write that in the ESL it's now converted
this into a number it's no you know
you've kind of written the string and
now it's realized it sir it's a number
so it's converted it into a number so
yeah we do some like automatic
formatting to to make it simpler for the
for the user to understand what's going
on so I kind of show random data but I
didn't so like matrix results so there's
a function random word and it can take a
parameter the second parameter can be a
number and I can be the number of the
number of random pieces of data that you
want so random word five should be five
random words so we see that this is
expanded into into a matrix which if we
wanted to change the size of the data we
could do this as well
every no I've seen the words come up I
don't know how this works exactly but
certainly some questionable words have
come up before in the past so like on
the theme of dates I you know a lot of
people like to do like they dates can be
a bit of a pain T to use in Excel dates
are very nice and the Wolfram language
so for example if we're going to just do
some small layer of computation here I
could say they range now they put D plus
now plus ten so the next bit the next
ten business days from from today so we
run this in in in in Mathematica first
and you can see the result now if we
wanted to do this in the in the cloud
connector with with Excel you can you
could ride this which is basically the
same thing and we'll just paste it into
a new sheet it doesn't maintain the zoom
so I can just place this in and it and
it should just it should just work which
is which is quite nice you can also like
reference values in Excel as well
I have a blue forefoot for zooming so
let's say so this so this code
references b2 so I can put a value in b2
and then just paste my code here so it
does you know the next ten days from
front from from now or whatever is in B
2 so this will this will dynamically
update if I if I change the values so so
that's how you you know that's how you
use the Wolfen function hey Abdul yeah
so if you want to define like a pure
function then you have to put the an
ampersand at the end yeah double quotes
is just so in excel at these the quote
escaping is is double quotes so it's if
there are other ways to escape quotes
for this is the best way I think it
looks clean enough it's still a little
bit confusing and something that we're
aware of but we can't avoid it because
this is how Excel does it so okay so
that was the wolf from the Wolfram
function so let's talk about double for
making hi function so this is a this is
a function where you deploy your API
functions in the cloud and then you can
access them from within Excel you call
them in Excel so you can use boat you
can create public or private API is
private to yourself private to a group
of individuals you know it just works
just works you no need to worry about
like any any any any details there so I
just wanted to show the example
spreadsheet so this is something that
you can download from the resources page
you see once you've where ever gotten to
so after they have to install I'll show
you that at some point you've got the
get an example spreadsheet and the
spreadsheet is here that's a very nicely
designed spreadsheet by Billy I don't
know Billy's here no but anyway he did a
good job at this and it just talks you
how to how to run these api's says like
empty a date into spreadsheet write your
Wolfram API function and then you can
change values and it will work and the
result is is here at the bottom but I'm
just going to go through these I'll run
the live coding thing I'll explain
things a little bit more detail so we've
already kind of seen grids of data
within the the Wolfram function in the
Wolfram API function the behavior is the
same so this is just returning a grid of
random of random integers between zero
and a thousand I think it doesn't tell
me actually here but there's some
there's some details if I want to have a
plot here you know this is this is
updating Oh Q yes so also one thing from
the necessary kind of useful information
is you know I've specified in the API
that it has to be a list of a list of
integers so it tells me here that the
the parameter data which is which is
here cannot be interpreted and it tells
you that it needs to be a list of
numbers that she doesn't have to be
integers it can be numbers so I should
be able to put in like 1.5 and this
should and this should work so the
errors are quite useful as well if you
want to have a grid so let me just
disable you can disable all the
functionality if you want to in the in
the menu and I'll just change all this
to two ones and then re-enable and we'll
should just see all these things this is
a single API call by the way is a single
API call which returns a grid of data
which is really really cool
think and the last example returns
details of you know if you're signed in
or not essentially and what your your
details are I don't know if these are
personal details or not this uu idea
might be but but yeah it gives you you
know I I got signed in and you can use
this information when you're when you're
writing your API functions so no no I
mean what API TSI api function isn't
quite unique to the cloud I mean you can
write an API function which you can
which you can call I mean I don't know
why you would want to do it but yeah I
will be showing it sure yeah I mean I
will show you like I'm gonna do this
live coding thing right worship where
I'll go into a little bit of detail but
basically this is a API function which
you deploy it takes a parameter X which
must be an integer and then it does the
day range thing that we had before so we
have before the Wolfram function which
did now date plus and then you specify
some some number and it'll give you the
business days between those between
those days and I've just wrapped it
around an API function so we can do an
eight you know a Wolfram API call
instead of a Wolfram core the only thing
that's different from a normal API
function is that you need to add this
parameter allowed cloud extra parameter
goes to all so I've called this this
function my day a function and if I run
this and for convenience I'm just going
to copy and paste this it's called my
day
a function add a range function and it
takes a parameter X which must be at c2
so in I'll have a new spreadsheet which
goes to c2 which takes 10 and I'll just
copy and paste this in and so it's just
calling my day array function where X is
c2 and it should just run so if I change
these values it will work as as the
Wolfram function did before but it's
wrapped around an API function and this
allows you greater granularity of like
you know what kind of parameters it can
take it also allows you to write more
complicated code because writing a long
string of just wool from pure Wolfram
language code in a cell can get very
messy very quickly so so yeah so I just
wanted to show you a little more more of
a potentially useful example I won't go
into the the the code too much but it's
this employee rotor that I that I made
which makes a rotor for four people
using the day rate function so you it
takes a start date and an end date and
then it does and you give you give a
list of names and it will it will create
an employee rotor for you so I'll just I
won't go into the details of the code
here because I realize I'm running out
of time
but basically I have a start date which
can be it can either be an Excel date or
a a computer date so I could say you
know today and then I could say today
plus 10 days and then I can say other
people who are going to be working
around just a good girly Topher Magali
Tom and my function was called well
actually I called his shift allocation
and it takes these parameters and then I
run this and it should make a rotor
ignoring any non business in on business
days in the UK so so that's how this
works ok so
let me just build an example relatively
quickly when I'm running out of time so
I just wanted to talk to you about how
you build these API functions because I
think it's pretty useful so I'm gonna
make an API function which takes a
parameter which I'm just going to call X
and it's going to take an image and that
image is going to be with that image I'm
just going to do color negate so it's
just going to negate whatever image
comes in like a there's another word for
cutting the gate what's the word I'm
thinking of girl in your view smart
sorry invert yeah that's right yes so I
put our loud Club extra parameters goes
to all and then I'm just gonna call this
test and it's gonna be a private API so
I have to be signed in so this is pretty
simple I think it'll work hopefully so
it's cool tests and it does color in the
gate of an image so I need an image so
I'm gonna use Bing because we love
Microsoft here so we're gonna search for
Emmett around the dock this is this is
this is who I am
look see look his is clip and everything
so I'm gonna save this image it's a JPEG
good put it on to desktop wait hang on
what's there what that's a weird format
I'm not sure what a J jjf I don't know
if that's important let's let's just try
this guy maybe I should have used Google
and I should have said that okay here we
go it's fine it's fine everything's fine
it wasn't it wasn't bings fault so so
got this image and let's open another
another sheet and what did I call it so
this image image 2019 so I go to my
Wolfram tab I insert a fire path and the
file is this image so it does like a
little file wrapper like in the Wolfram
language it was cool test right and then
there was a parameter X which should be
this image and hopefully I haven't very
rushed it's just work
hey so there we go there's my color
negated image of the doc so so yeah that
was just a simple live coding example I
want to do something a bit more advanced
but I'm out of time so very quickly I
just want to mention about the
documentation so the documentation you
know you can get to it from the
resources page on the on the main
website there's an introduction the main
pages that you want to look at is the
setup and getting started it shows you
like how to install setting your
preferences signing in it talks about
developers and Excel users so developers
you know who want to create api's and
deploy them and and Excel users who just
want to access API is the example
spreadsheet that I showed you is in the
Wolfram API examples thing and it talks
you through all the examples from an
Excel user point of view and how to run
these run these functions just in Excel
and then for the developers we talked
about the code and how you write the
code for these for these examples which
which obviously is quite useful so you
can you have something something to go
on so we talked about the Wolfram
function and there different ways that
you can there seems to be something
missing here
oh no it's more Wolfram function
examples so it goes through all the
different ways that you can construct
Wolfram functions with the with the
additional parameters yes okay so I have
13 seconds is fine
so other ways to interact with Excel
import/export
so you all of you probably seen this but
yeah if you want to import a spreadsheet
you just can just use import this one
just imports images I got this Halloween
spreadsheet for you guys as well because
I wanted to be Halloween themed export
works in the same way so if you wanted
to export this pie chart with some
additional values you can use export
what else so there's the excel link the
excel link allows you to call excel to
mathematical or mathematical to excel
this is something that's existed for a
while but if you wanted to do that let's
just scroll down here there's a function
I've got it installed equals eval which
which allows you to to again to call
Wolfram language code within within
Excel hopefully this just works but I
wanted to show you a quick example it
takes some time to to load up actually
yes yes so this does not use the cloud
is only for local calls for for Excel to
Mathematica and then you can do it in
indeed the other way around where you
can use the Excel link pack Pacolet to
write to excel and then read to excel so
it's just a sum 1 2 3 and then you know
sum of 1 2 3 is 6 so you can make your
own Excel link if you wanted to and this
is something that I've been working on
for for testing purposes for the cloud
connector but if you use net link you
can load your assemblies I don't know if
this is actually gonna work because the
things aren't highlights it correctly
but I made a function so I can find out
what version of Excel I'm using I can
make a workbook and then I can make a
new version of Excel right which uses a
net block which adds the value excels
weird and just set a value use value two
so you set value 2 to the value
and here I'm writing equals five plus
five and I can make a new version of of
Excel read and and do that as well so
this isn't particularly interesting is
going to show you the same thing but the
Excel driver Packer is something that
I've been working on which is I can
enhance capabilities of the excel link
to be able to do things like shape
manipulation and stuff like that some
things that the original Excel link
doesn't do so if that's something that
you're interested in seeing this is
something that we can be putting put up
on github and and polish up and things
like that so please talk to me
afterwards if that's of interest yeah so
yeah concluding remarks yeah so you can
call native Wolfram language or API
functions from within Excel using the
cloud connector it's a product that's
available to download now I kind of
showed you multiple ways to interact
with Microsoft Excel and and wolfram
products although I did it very quickly
and next week we should be releasing a
blog which it will be the official
announcement for the for the cloud
connector